welcome thank you so much for coming
ten seconds with myself my name is
Victor oh damn he's shooting this I need
to stand there I hate this I hate this
my name is Victor and this is the slide
that you need to know about me my name
my Twitter is over here and my twitter
is conveniently placed on all the slides
if you want to tweet about the session
and this is important you have to tweet
because there's some demo around Twitter
and live streams of tweets that will be
used and I work at a company called
confluent and I worked there as a
developer advocate I build highly
scalable and highly available a world
world applications and we were going to
be building some of those today with me
and I'm building stuff around magic
after bad about stream processing from
every and whatever developer and he was
like what like what what why this guy is
even here but there's interesting
backstory here before I moved to Java
world I actually started as a C++
and.net developer I started with dotnet
1.1 and moved to dotnet 2.0 and my my my
graduation work at the University that
also was my kind of sort of some some
work that I did for internship when I
was working in a bank was written in is
p.net 2.0 there was very interesting
times but when I moved to to to do some
PG work my professors say said this
stuff not gonna fly here so I need to
learn Java so I was doing Joe but this
talk about for for for dotnet developers
and necessarily you need to be like
content developers to understand this
now I'm kind of talking about mostly
usually talking to the beta engineers
I'm talking to developers the engineers
do we have any like people who do
anything with some big data tools and
heard about Kafka at least something
today all right so that's that's which
is pretty cool for those of you who don
here you will learn a lot of things
today and in order to explain something
the way how I like to explain things to
people I lie
to go with explaining three things
basically why what and how so I will
start explaining why at the very
beginning the the world didn't know but
that the world needs Apache Kafka and
now world heaven so when we built the
problem you to stand here sure is it
okay if I will stand like like this the
camera cameraman is it fine perfect yeah
so we're building software in
organizations and our companies we build
software as a company to sell software
there are some companies who build
software to run the business and
software's everywhere and when we're
building the software every interaction
that happening in in in all business
processes that we're doing involve
stream of data stream of a different
events but essentially what we do with
building our application we're building
some sort of data store after that we
have some persistent layer that reads
that from the data pushes this to
business logic layer and after that
withdrawing this in some sort of
front-end so we're building data stores
where we need to you know build actually
data flows in our organizations now and
the typical typical world of enterprise
architecture at the price applications
look something like this so we're
starting with some small applications
that requires one database this this
application might be interactive some
other applications through API might be
interacting some other ssss system would
also through some sort of API so there's
a few seats over here so if you want to
come come and sit there's a some room
over here
so and usually in as we grow or as we
progress into different aspects of our
application architecture we start seeing
that some other people doing some other
stuff within our organization or within
I don't know maybe would try to
integrate with partners we're trying to
integrate
different services we're trying to
integrate this with some other systems
and now we get this idea that okay so we
need to get the data for our application
from somewhere that we previously did so
we need to get maybe another API call or
maybe we can integrate through through
database we can have some tools that
will take and replicate their database
in our database this is what data data
engineering look like and essentially we
end up here
so we how many of you actually see in
something like that like any like a
consultants here any people who you know
we're coming to on board and after that
you meeting this architect he like let
me explain let me explain you how this
stuff works here right so and he
explaining how this stuff worked like
from 10 years ago and how everything
involved and now you feel sorry about
this person and actually this is stuff
that I'm seeing when I was talking to
customers I'm not always talking to
developers I used to be in professional
services did the consultancy so I seen
those people and interesting enough even
a web scale companies like LinkedIn
might have a similar problem not not
this one but like this specific problem
right so multiple systems they need to
integrate they when the LinkedIn was is
still kind of like a scrappy startup
they were trying to figure out the ways
how different some components can be
develop a stir there's kind of search
will get updated from some of the
results that user putting in their
profiles so this why they face this
problem they decide to do something with
this so and what they they what they did
they didn't do this and from day one
they started developing thing that was
far far far from the whatever we seen
right now and they start developing
thing called petrikov and only today or
maybe only right now we can call it as a
event streaming platform as something
that really really new category of the
software but what is the event streaming
platform and this is what I'm trying to
I will try to answer today so the way
how eventually platformer idea evolved
from the from this like a pre streaming
world in the world of when the data was
sort in databases and warehouses stuff
that was in this data Silas was was
supposed to go to somewhere and we need
to start moving this data out where we
need to break down certain analytic
applications into more micro service
approach this is where the event shaming
evil streaming platform transformed the
ways how the system interact instead of
communicating directly or communicating
through database or communicate through
API or communicating through any other
integration system integration ways the
in the world of like streaming data
stuff start moving into in this approach
and also enabled a lot of real-time use
cases how when you heard about this the
couple killed lamda architecture let's
start with lamda architecture any Big
Data folks here who knows that there's a
lamda architecture where we have bash
layer and have stream layer batch layer
usually more precise because it has all
the data streaming data streaming layer
will give you some immediate result but
because some of the events some of the
data my arrive later you don't have
precise result so after moving to this
from the from the batch or ancient world
into more streaming world there was
evolution of this lambda detection the
cap architecture that removed this batch
or Hadoop or Medusa type operations
because tools matured and the tools
learn how to deal with late events and
how to you know process data that
already arriving later now from
perspective of you understanding this
stuff and you can you know whatever you
can tell to your colleagues after this
talk you need to understand three things
Oh someone's try to connect to my laptop
to display something we don't want to do
this right we don't want it we don't
want to see it no so I will go ahead and
kill my where's my server I will prevent
prevent four so one shown you know what
happened
recently some people actually sent some
nasty stuff through airdrop so do not
forget this kind of like sticky
information security hygiene through
airdrop just disable it or have it on
for the contacts okay for the purpose of
this presentation and for the purpose of
this talk I have a limited time sorry
you busy people I want to explain you
three things that help you understand
what the hell is eventually platform
right so and again I did mention that
the Apache Kafka is event shaming
platform there are some systems that
follow similar ideas and this over the
time you start evolving into something
similar but applied Chicago is still
right now one of the one of the leading
pieces of the software that people using
to do is okay we're going to be focusing
on three things we're gonna be focusing
on the storage we're gonna be focusing
on the pops up pattern because sometimes
people think that Apache cough is a
messaging system who thinks the patch
Kafka's messaging system good I already
teach you already something yet you
you're good you good you people and
you're learning very quickly because you
already know that the petrikov case vent
streaming platform so when I start the
conversation usually with people saying
yeah yeah we know this it's like I don't
know like Microsoft MQ or maybe like SNS
or Google pops up or whatever messaging
system they know Apache Kafka it's like
elephant from the story of blind people
and elephant how many heard about the
story okay
so for those who don't know a bunch of
blind people I run into elephant and
because they were blind they were
touching different parts of the elephant
and from the parts that they touch they
trying to figure out what kind of animal
it is someone touch do you know sometime
touch the tail and they have different
you know view on this one so this white
same story with a Patrick rafter depends
of whoever I'm talking to if I'm talking
to myself in guys saying oh it's a
measuring system if I'm talking to
database guys oh it's another weird
database whatever thing if I'm talking
to people who knows how to run a
MapReduce oh it is a system that allows
to MapReduce ingestion or data ingestion
into MapReduce to spark jobs or so far
so on which brings us to the point of
number three of processing it's cool
when we can bring data just the push
data in a read data out with trying to
I'll try to show you how
how you can do something useful this
data and I'm doing this in only possible
in only one possible way how I know and
just like asking people to tweet stuff
and after that I will be processing this
tweet tweets in real time so we're gonna
talk about this now let's talk about
storage a little quick different systems
when we're talking about different data
systems you need to establish some score
abstractions we're talking about
databases we're talking about tables if
we're talking about Hadoop and HDFS
we're talking about things like files
but what is the core abstraction for
Apache Kafka any guesses any guesses
look exactly log it is log it is a data
structure that is fundamental core
abstraction for Apache Kafka what is log
you probably heard this term multiple
times because we're developers we like
to write logs and after that based on
this information and the log we can can
analyze what is happening and if you
think about this what log has it has set
of Records and usually because you're
using this as a source of truth to
figure out what the hell is going on
with your system those records are
immutable and they ordered by certain
order right usually it's based on time
so you will be able to read any log from
the beginning of the file until the end
so you understand what's going on with
the system so the same abstraction
placed into the is a foundation
foundational core abstraction for some
some data systems they called LOC log
base data systems actually there is
probably three fundamental data
structure that any software in journeyed
x' to know so log because even database
relational database based on the
transactional log system hash map right
so you need to know how the hashing
algorithm works because all these
distributed systems somehow inherit this
hash map pattern and how the data is
distributed across multiple the buckets
or part
or how cold or and probably be three yb3
how many of you who went to the United
States alright how many of you been
interrogated and with the enhanced
interrogation techniques when you said
I'm a developer and the officer told you
okay if you developer you probably know
how to do like the bypass of b3 and
explain how you can do this b3 search
not only for that like if you if you get
the bison jr. you need to know that the
b3 is used to build indexes and
databases but also useful when you're
trying to to us alright so back to log
same idea you already know this because
you're writing into the end of the file
you're reading from the beginning of the
file messages or like if different
records here are immutable
they mutable and you cannot changes if
you want to change something if you not
change the state of the world you send
another message it's a similar to have a
conversation with your significant other
and you said something yet not supposed
to say and now you cannot change that
you cannot change it you need to send
you need to send another message to
amend this and this is where latency is
important depends on how this system
receiving system will be receiving in
processing this data right so this is
also very important this is why latency
is important now again we're reading
from from beginning of the file and to
the end of the file next now you know
logs so go to point number two so how
this pops up thing works so that's why
it looks like a what like a queue right
people saying you're writing to the end
of the file to the end of the queue and
reading from the from the beginning of
the file or begin from the queue looks
like a queue right so this why it is
very popular pattern of using cough
cases messaging system so what does it
mean data that we put inside the Kafka
we know that formed inside this logs we
call these logs partitions these
partitions can be spread across multiple
broker nodes we have many many broker
nodes we can have a thousand nodes 100
nodes two nodes as well
we can logically organize those
partitions in the things that we call
topics so topics is something that
probably your application will be using
to produce to or consume fro topics
might have one partition or many
partitions we're writing data into this
partition this is how it looks like now
we have on the other side we have a
consumers who read this data in the in
the in the in order how this data was
written into this file and there is
multiple type of consumers and this is
where things getting a little bit
interesting and a little bit different
how the people would know from the
messaging system so if you do dealing
with any messaging system before what
you do when you read the message you
acknowledge and the messaging system
will remove this message from from the
queue if you do in topic maybe a
messaging system will distribute this
information to different consumers or
listeners and after that if they will
receive acknowledgement from dependency
dependent depend depend on depend on
like a pattern of like a durable
consumption or or not it will remove
this with Kafka it's not like this Kafka
has more common with distributed
database then it has with messaging
system because when the consumers
consuming these messages they consume in
with their own speed with their own pace
they can do different things with this
data
I'll give you example for example I'm
reading a book and the way how I'm
reading the book slightly different from
the people in in in English world
because English is the second language
for me so this why I need to use
vocabulary to look up certain words
that's why my reading pattern of the
same book would be different from your
reading pattern and the speed would be
different
my son's reading pattern would be even
different from all of you because he's
really moved much more faster because he
don't care about letters in the books
he's trying to find the pictures in the
book but but we still reading same book
we still look into the same file with
this look into the same log so if we if
I were trying to translate the same same
explanation to messaging world every
time you're reading something from the
book it's you're down the page and after
that if someone was late to the party on
the very beginning they will not be able
to understand what the hell's going on
with Kafka we use this concept called
offsets think about bookmarks you read
the book you know where you stopped you
put the bookmark so next time when you
start reading the same book you're
getting back to this to this offset you
read this and saying oh okay I stop here
and again I mentioned that multiple
consumers might have a different
patterns of consuming the data will talk
about consumers in few more seconds now
distributed system how many will heard
about consistent hashing algorithm
that's why I brought up
consistent hashing or hashing functions
how it's done for those of you who don't
know this consistent hashing algorithm
it's it's or different variations of
this algorithm apply to majority of
distributed distributed systems
distributed databases so far and so on
simply because it by agreeing on certain
algorithm of key distribution you can
actually win in simplicity of
architecture so you don't need to have
some sort of like a service discovery
you don't need to have some sort of note
that knows where is they did
simply because you know the key and you
agree on hashing function you take a key
apply hashing function you get some
number after that divide this number by
number of partitions in this particular
case the partitions in topic and we get
some number where we place this data so
why it's called consistent because there
is consistency between clients how the
clients will discover the data
inconsistency between the the brokers
over the servers or nodes
how this data would be placed into other
another nodes now Kafka use same
approach to balance this data across
across the multiple partitions and also
it creates very interesting very
interesting side effect so if we will be
putting data with the same key every
square here it represents a pair of key
value messages inside Kafka has a key in
case value if you're using same key but
different value
this data will land on the same
partition meaning that you will be have
order preserved the same way how this
message was initially produced which is
also creates very interesting quality
that Kafka knows that some sort of
ordering guarantees right so if you do
consider producing some of the messages
that were involved in to credit card
payment processing and based on the
credit card IG or or some sort of like
account ID all these transactions will
land in the same order how they happened
and you don't need to worry that your
consumer will get some messages out of
the order so this is guaranteed that
built in into Kafka using this
consistent hashing algorithm if you
didn't specify the key it's also not a
problem
Kraft producer will choose the key for
you it will be just simply do
round-robin and placing it where
whatever it's suitable so basically it
will try to balance across now let's get
back to consumption once again so like I
mentioned multiple consumers can read
the data with their own speed so this
why all these consumers they focus in
this in the same state of the world the
same same source of truth and now they
can read data with the pace that they
okay over it
Kafka is a database special type of
database but it doesn't mean that Kafka
will be suitable for all use cases like
random accessing so there is no random
access even though there is the keys of
value so in case you want to do some of
the randomizing you need to offload data
from the Kafka topics using Kafka
connect we cannot be talking about a
little bit and after that perform
whatever the random access search that
we know we can upload this to radius we
can flow this to hazel caste or some
some some other system this is also very
important slide this is very important
slide will help you to explain one of
the core features of Apache Kafka cool
consumer groups doesn't look like it
right but being a kind of engineer we
need to put some of the description to a
picture okay in the world of Kafka we
have all these consumers can be grouped
in the so-called consumer group and the
reason for that is that Kafka optimized
for reads and the way how the you
reading faster from the Kafka topic is
by increasing number of consumers in
consumer group does make any sense let
me explain this using this picture so
there is a special special process that
runs inside one of the brokers when they
run your application establish
connection to Kafka broker one of the
one of the broker nodes become a
consumer group controller or also known
as a mammy mammy bird so mommy bird is
responsible for our registry buting and
assigning all these partitions once you
want to consume some data from
particular topic mommy bird knows that
all these worms need to go to the baby
birds and because there is only one
consumer and consumer group all this
worms will go to one baby bird now we
seen that one of the baby birds is
choking because there's too many worms
to eat so this why we starting another
consumer in this in this case two more
consumers now mommy bird will be
responsible for balancing this load and
distribute this distribute this message
just distribute this partition across
all these three papers so let's have
example here about three partitions in
one topic meaning that we have not three
ten let's do ten they will have a ten
partitions in our topic and imagine
three three worms why same three the the
ten ten ones in 310 so in this case this
guy will have a three it's get for these
four because they are part of the same
consumer group now if there would be new
baby bird that will hatch from this from
the egg right now and join consumer
group mommy bird will stop feeling
meaning that let me translate this to
engineering language consumer group
controller will will stop
all consumption will do rebalance all
these partitions and after that continue
the consumers will continue consume the
data and also here you might notice some
of the difference between the systems
that you have of messaging system where
your messaging system pushes some data
but in Kafka all this consumption is
actually consumer driven so consumers
will be requesting more and more food
and mommy bird will be responsible for
providing more and more food now
question to the audience in the same
situation when we have a ten worms any
partitions if we have a 11 baby birds
what's gonna happen just kind of open
microphone you can shout what's gonna
happen what who's that serving starving
exactly so this is very interesting
point so when we have a same number of
partitions than number of consumers in
the consumer groups we have one to one
relationship and we potentially can
start more consumers that the joint a
single but they will do nothing they
will be idling because there is no work
right so this is also very interesting
point of a Patrick rafter where you can
have end-to-end orden guaranteed
production of the data in consumption
data so we have a system that produces
your credit-card transaction information
and you need to perform some sort of
computation of the data that comes
through this for this kafka topic in
order how these messages were arrived so
we have a same number of your consumers
as number of partitions and you have a
end-to-end ordering guarantee but
picture is nice alright so let me
explain this into the in the language
that engineers will understand with the
boxes and arrows when we have a topic
with four partitions all both partitions
will be assigned to one consumer if we
might have multiple consumer groups
remember I will give you example how
we're reading books me and my son we are
representing two different consumer
groups because we are presenting
different applications we're
representing different use case that are
interested
than this data so same thing is I've
consumed when your application starts
you need to specify consumer group ID in
this case consumer group controller will
be responsible for managing all the
stuff for you and when we have two
different consumer groups all these
consumer groups will be consuming data
with their own speed because they have
at their own ways how to process this
data when we have a one-to-one a
relationship between number of
partitions in number of consumers in
consumer group we will have kind of like
end-to-end flow and assignment of
partitions will be represented the same
way how it was assigned in the topic
what if one of this consumers will go
down assignment would be placed to to
another consumers or some of the
consumers will be receiving messages
from two partitions so let me summarize
this so we have a producers that not
depend on any consumers we have a
consumers who also don't depend on this
so consumers is over here producers are
over here and in the middle here we have
this broker that responsible for
handling this data so the cool thing
about this diagram is that your key can
scale different aspects of your
application if your application needs to
produce data faster you start more more
more producers if your application needs
to consume this data faster you learn
that there's consumer groups that are
using the multiple consumers in the
consumer group we are allowed to do a
parallel reads and also in in the middle
craft brokers you can scale them also
independently in case of you want to
provide more more serious resiliency and
so far and so on now there is a special
special there's something special in in
in the Kafka as a as a project few
components that we learn already it's a
producer consumer in the brokers it's
usually where everything ends for many
people they just start okay because it's
a messaging system bla bla bla I will be
doing using this one but craft as a open
source product or open source tool is
actually much more so let me switch to
this one so okay
a peshkov could also includes this the
framework that is a part of the Apache
Kafka project called Kafka Connect so it
is a framework for sorry for Java
developers to develop these connectors
but as a developer who don't care about
the geologists or maybe a data engineer
you just need to bring data into that
out you don't need to know Java at this
case connect allows you just get the
prepackaged connector and just ship this
and start this process and start pumping
data from anywhere virtually from any
source or pump data virtually to any
source I will be using a connector from
Twitter today so that's why reminder to
tweet about this session using hashtag
and the sea Sydney and how the data will
lend I don't know because I never wrote
this connector and I don't know how to
work with Twitter API so this why I just
took the connector of the shelf that
allowed me to do to read this data from
Twitter now in case of deployment
deployment is supported to any possible
any possible tool you can deploy this as
rpm package you can deploys the Debian
package you can run this in the
container you can run this in queries
there is a managed platform like we
build confluent cloud which is managed
platform for Apache Kafka and all
streaming platforms we support
deployment of certain connectors there
as well and this is like way how you can
build data pipelines fairly easy without
writing any code another thing craft
provides the way how data would be
replicated it also built in many
messaging systems adding this kind of
capabilities as afterthought craft has
from the day one from the from the not
from the day one it you have it as a
Kafka user from the day one Kafka
actually developed this over the time
but it's it's good that it's there so
the way how its how it's done in terms
of how data will be securely safe on
other nodes the partitions certain
partitions might be a linear partition
some partitions will be replica
partitions you see Kafka was very
advanced a tool and Kafka was very
progressive tool in terms of diversity
and
fighting against all this like slaves
and masters and stuff so from day one
there were leaders and their followers
right so craft girl was always progress
if in this case your producer and
consumer always read data and always
write data to leader partition this is
how Kafka pers performs their you know
consistency grantees so once the data
was acknowledged and written to leader
so consumer will get the same set of
world there's no there's no eventual
consistency where you some of the
consumers can can read this from from
replicas and this replicas might not
have fresh information if the replica
will go down one of the note will go
down what's going to happen some of
these follower replicas will take over
responsibilities of leaders so as you
can see here we have this partition
number four that was stored on the node
number four I said what Hanna happened
is partition number four replica of
partition number four from the broker
number two will be take over
responsibility of later so and there's
different things that can be configured
different acknowledgement behind how we
can do from the producer side of
consumer side so let's kind of like
let's summarize so log is a special type
of a durable messaging system similar to
tradition the messaging system but
better scalability better fault
tolerance and also allows you to always
replay and read the data even after the
data was produced but yours down or
something like that cool let's do some
demo right relax it's not Twitter demo
yet so since we're talking about dotnet
here there are where's my yeah so first
of all I want to show you something to
to to explain that I'm legit here so
there is a project called c-sharp client
for Apache Kafka that developed by
Microsoft and
now they recommend to use confluent
kafka dotnet so this is where this is
where like we're starting into into the
into the game what counseling does so as
a company we also sponsoring development
of open source Apache Kafka if you will
go and see Kafka Patchett or you'll see
multiple people who work at Comfort
actually committing to this open source
project plus would you would you support
development of certain open source
clients for Apache Kafka dotnet is
included and as you can see even we got
this confirmation from the Microsoft
that even Microsoft people recommend to
use confluent net client it's a valuable
nugget so you can go there and grab it
so you can get the source code some of
the examples that I'm going to be
showing today you can see on this github
page and let's let's try to produce
something another thing that you as a
developer I want to start with Apache
Kafka you either need like I've deployed
somewhere or you can get this package
from Apache website or you can get the
package from our website because this
package includes certain tools that
allows you to be more productive as a
developer specifically there's a
confluence CLI that allows you to start
to stop graph to stop starting stop
different components of the kafka so you
will be able to do stuff locally and
after most importantly it allows you to
erase whatever crap you did because we
make some mistakes we do some bugs so
you don't need to go and track this down
and figuring out why your stuff is not
working because there is a like start
from scratch comment out of the box
which is my favorite feature of this
platform when I said it's available
somewhere in the cloud so we do have
managed service that's available in Asia
as well Microsoft have thing called HD
inside which is there a big data stack
and Kafka is a part of hdinsight so
choose whatever you like to use we will
also run in Asia if you're running there
now so let's do let's take a look on
local local development and how it looks
like let me switch to to some of this
stuff that I'm gonna be using all right
I already running my status ok so I
already running my Kafka I'm running my
zookeeper Kafka depends on zookeeper but
it's not very long zookeeper lived there
for maybe last year we're working to
remove this in scheme registry
it's a rest arrest service that I use to
store some of the data about some
metadata about my data so imagine we
live in the world where the different
developers develop their application in
the language of their choice crazy right
so I can develop in Java you can develop
a net they don't see can be friends we
don't need to like fight against against
each other anymore
so schema allows us to define the
contract that we communicate or format
of the message or like if I'm translated
to engineering world with serialization
the Association for word Kafka doesn't
care what kind of stuff you're putting
inside Kafka don't do introspection
doesn't do this civilization on the
broker side because Kafka has this
concept of zero copy meaning that when
the data goes through from the network
into the craft craft streams is directly
from this network socket into the file
system so even though Kafka written on
Java there is no much of the garbage
created by producing a lot of messages
because we're relying on a low-level
system calls there so and given the fact
that it's just as some sort of like a
payload some sort of bytes Kafka don't
care my clients care so in this case if
I'm reading data or writing data in
dotnet or go I want to read this data
into Java and Python so this is why I am
using a schema and there's example that
that shows how we can do so let me start
this enter on localhost'
so in this case I need specify address a
broker I need to specify a topic with
some schema and now I can start
producing something into this into this
topic because my craft is up and I can
start writing something like I don't
know let's put something interesting
where is it a username so let's see if
you get the reference did you did you
yeah
anyone anyone best Christmas movie
little weapon anyone I may be another
[Music]
another best Christmas movie
alright so I just produced two two
messages so in this case messages land
in the Kafka topic so what I can do to
read those I can use my the C sharp
consumer to read this but I was trying
to sell you kind of sort of
cross-platform thing so let's see how I
can do if I do there's a craft console
consumer I need to specify okay let's do
this so we don't need this we don't need
this because we're using localhost 1922
and topic was a topic topic with schema
and is she here I start doing this from
beginning I just you know with this data
and is happen to display this data
correctly even though I didn't specify
any schema and stuff just simply because
the way how the Avro handles schemas
handles strings is actually you know
cross-platform it's just placed there
like the unique what form so that's why
I can read this word a similar consumer
which not working in the cases where I
need to run some of the binary data if
I'll put in some of the numbers there so
I will see some of the some of the stuff
in this case I need to actually use is
Kafka Avro consumer and when I will
reading this data in every format I will
actually
get full full thing that I'm expecting I
see schema I see how my object should
look like and also you might notice my
application still I can still do some of
the production but I still this my
consumer was not available or didn't
start before before I start producing
this messages so let's do what's another
famers a Christmas movie maybe right
home alone it's another also the robbery
type of movie in the Christmas so same
thing with die hard right so in this
case you cannot say that die heart is
not Christmas movie so so first of all
you see my application continue to
working so I'm reading data as it
arrives but also like on the very
beginning I specified that I want to
read this from beginning meaning that
like every time I I'm sorry let me do
this so you will be able to see no you
will not be able to see I will make it
work for you yeah so here I'm specifying
that I need to read this topic from
beginning meaning that every time I'm
resetting my I've set I'm starting this
reading this book from the very
beginning and this is how I you know
consuming in producing consume and
produce data in this in this application
again I will continue to do this if I
will start this application without
specifying this from beginning meaning
that I will be listening only for the
fresh data this is how you can emulate
the same behavior you have any messaging
system because you're starting only from
real-time data and here you're doing
something like this and will get some
data so you get the point so we do have
a bunch of a bunch of for example
application that can integrate with
different just simple producer-consumer
if you not in this average as I've seen
there some of the Jura PC talks here so
probably you're doing some of the plot
above stuff we have some example how we
can do this like wrote above it's
another format that allows you to define
schema and based on the schema generate
some of the cross-platform
representation and also like we do have
example how you can write data in and
read data from the confluent cloud you
can adopt this example to did you and
connect to any service that you using in
terms of this so if you've seen if
you've been in the one of the industry
conferences in the past there was a talk
about Kafka in the past and they were
using the slightly different API right
now API is much more fluid much more
nicer to use so for example there is a
strongly type producer config so you'd
need to go and create like a generic the
dictionary if you need to provide this
configuration the API is more fluent you
can know whatever stuff you need to put
this in this particular case there is
some of the bootstrap server information
some other configs so the client itself
is evolving and it also involving on on
to being like a native API it would be
in a tool with this some of the idea
magic API is that available or Net+ this
this this client depends on the library
called Liberty Kafka which is C
implementation and this this is the
foundation for many open-source clients
including Python including go including
some of the dot sorry no GS clients that
use Liberty Kafka and this this client
is fully compatible with all modern
features of Apache Kafka so this is this
is basic foundation this is how you
start this is how you're doing this so
let's move on to to processing aspect
now you learn how you produce data in
read data out so let's do some of the
complex stuff so this is where we're
going to be talking about finger they
call stream processing or streaming or
processing stream of events and things
like that so essentially as data arrived
we want to make some of the decisions we
want to make some of the processing we
need to do something with this data as
it arrived into system not that we
collecting this data and
after that we'll do computation at the
end of the day no it is so 2002 because
right now we can and we will process
data it arrived because we have
increased number of of the ways how we
can generate this data our business
evolved because we cannot rely on on
some of these like obsolete data from
the from the past now we need to make
some decisions based on some real-time
data we would like to call this not even
the real-time there's even complex more
more complex aspect here like how you
combine the real-time data with data
that a historical has some some
historical meanings and this why all
these new applications would call them
contextual event streaming application
where we combine real-time aspect that
comes from the for example some of the I
don't know sensors like like GPS on your
phone and combining this with data that
come that was stored in our in our
system for example some of the CRM
system and based on the CRM data we can
join and get some of the better
experience to our customers and one of
the examples I want to use here just
simply I like this example simply cuz
people listen because people always
listen when talk about money especially
credit card transactions or little
payments or like Ledger's balances all
this stuff people love this so this is
why this example will stick into your
mind because this is about fraud fraud
protection so like especially like very
close to my heart because I travel and
like my credit card can be stolen or it
can be can't be not stolen can be
blocked because of the some of the
system with my bank will think oh some
fraudulent transaction how we can do
that I'm using very sophisticated
algorithm here to do this so let's just
say if recession attempts from same
credit card happened within five minute
window let's just say three more than
three authorization attempt happen we
can consider this as a fraudulent
activity so this why we have a input
stream of events that have authorization
attempts for particular credit card
number now we need to analyze the stream
on the fly and make a decision if this
turns our
fraudulent and only if it's a fraudulent
we need to create the record in this
called possible fraud topic or stream
that will include information about
credit card and some other system we'll
decide what you do next so as a matter
of fact this is a full-blown stream
processing application believe me or not
so this is where things get interesting
like Victor where's the net like where's
Java why where's the oldest kind of how
we can build this application so we
start working on this stream processing
world very on the very early stages and
we were pioneers we were able to do
development on the tools that we know
like Java Scala blah blah blah but over
the time we understand there are other
people in this world like other
engineers who interesting this one right
and I have a specific slide to prove to
prove me so we start thinking okay how
we can make how we can translate the
same of the same of the idea of shrimp
processing into these tools that people
can use without knowing java.net or or
whatever right so people know sequel how
many of you know sequel how many you've
been on the interview when they asking
you about sequel right this is this most
important thing like if you can answer
the interview how many of you know how
to do left join in MSS sequel I'm just I
don't know you're good you're good guys
awesome so now we're creating this
something called stream this is where we
have a certain discrepancy between our
thing and standard sequel there's no
keyboard stream we call it the possible
fraud and this stream will be populated
from events that you write from
authorization attempts stream where we
need to define a window so we actually
want to see if this authorization event
the resolution attempts happened within
certain window we just make this
assumption that 5-minute window no one
actually will be spending or sliding
this credit card often that
five minutes probably who designed the
cell they didn't never met my wife
doesn't matter go in go in next we
interested only in credit card number
and how many authorization tab happened
with with the five-minute window and
we're grouping this by card number and
we saying the count needs to be more
than three so this is a legitimate trim
processing application that can generate
some of the possible fraud output and
some of the things that can notice here
it's not just a simple filtering when we
need to read the impasse this true it's
actually involved some of the state
storage things like how we would know
how many messages we collect it over the
five minutes like where this data came
from and they're like because in order
to calculate the result for particular
step we need to know some data from the
past this is what's the difference
between stately stream processing in
stateful sim processing and the things
like key sequel that I'm going to be
talking right now it is actually knows
how to do this and knows how to you know
provide your storage spoiler alert
actually uses cough cases storage to to
store the state so yeah so this is where
we are like oh yeah everyone knows
Carlin Java no not everyone so we do
have a lot of people data engineers who
don't give a damn about Scala at all or
some date engineers who know with sync
over or some of the data engineers who
know some of the BI tools very well and
this is where we actually start
addressing this group of people who
interested in performing stream
processing operations without knowing a
programming so key sequel you can
iterate it degrade with the key sequel
through UI we have this development tool
called control center also I can be used
for monitoring you just if you get this
confluent the package control center and
code here you can use key sequel with UI
as engineers we love CLI I'm gonna be
using CLI all the way today also you can
use this for the rest interface so
sometimes there's some some
the interactivity that required to
submit these queries and this is
actually you can say it's kind of like a
week play because people asking me hey
where's this like stream processing
library for.net and saying yeah you know
we just developed this case sequel thing
so you can actually use case sequel from
your.net application a submit whatever
complex stream processing application
you want written in sequel through the
rest and after that you can get a result
through Kafka topic and this result will
be published and will be available for
multiple consumers again remember in the
picture with the baby birds and also it
is has it has a headless mode where we
can actually pack this file that
includes my icicle state rules and
deploy this in the server and after that
it will be constantly running reading
data from Kafka topic processing this
data and putting data back in Kafka
topic so the way how it the interaction
looks like the k sequel server can run
independently you still can run your
applications we can write any type of
application you can produce data from
from your application and write dates
into Kafka and again cool think about
this these components can be scaled
independently so you don't need to you
don't need to worry about some of the
like larger use case and small use cases
you can always start with small and
after that go go all the way with all
this kind of things all right so let's
see let's see some of the real world sim
processing and the way how we're going
to be looking at real world stream
processing let me do this full screen
and I'm doing this so here's my key
sequel let me do let me to exit so
you'll see very nice banner that you
will see that we actually in a key
sequel so the way how it works I'm
actually running this cluster in my in
my kubernetes in my kubernetes account
so if I do
choo-choo-choo Cabrera's get pods
let's see multiple thing
running here so I'm running my three
notes of Kafka broker running through no
zookeeper and I'm running my connect
Twitter connector so if I will go here
and see if I have any data I can do
select okay bless you select let's see
where's my username okay so if anyone
wants to tweet about me using NDC
hashtag you will be able to see your
your your tweet on this screen and
you'll see a bunch of tweets because
again I already tested this tweet about
myself things like that so but this is
what we're calling continuous query
so right now what is happening I
connected to this Kafka cluster and I
starting reading from the top of my
Twitter even though there were some
tweets I'm not showing this to you so
I'm giving opportunity to tweet about
this and you will see you to it on this
on the screen if you don't want to do
this I will do what what what we Russian
people known of doing is creating a
bunch of fake Twitter accounts and tweet
about ok so when you see the same a as
they memos is yep yep we're programming
is tweeting about kiss equal right and
if I will tweet if I will tweet we
should see this tweet on the stage if I
didn't make any mistake let's go to
space and Twitter or firehose will fire
this event there is connector that
listens for a particular event and
someone already tweet this here huh it
works and where's my where's my where's
my tweet where's my tweet the cool thing
about this case equal understand Unicode
first of all you will see there is some
of the
beautiful characters and there should be
something from from my me because my my
guy okay okay I even like failed to type
my username correctly what a what a
loser okay alright okay and this those
people asking us to tweet the body okay
so let's do this because Twitter
sometimes not allowed to do this the
most important thing I wanted to show
you here is that key sequel is actually
supporting emojis emojis okay so cool
the jokes aside if I want thank you
thank you very much this is what you get
when you're trying to do live tweeting
them on the stage right thank you people
compliment in your appearance I'm trying
so by default we reading only on the
real-time event so meaning that hours
continuous query was not was not there
during the time where we are tweeting
something but I'm actually running this
this this thing for a while right now
and it actually collecting a lot of data
and like a lot of tweets so in this case
I'm going here and I'm resetting my
offset so that's why when I starting
doing this
select once again I'm replaying this
kafka topic in order to do all this kind
of computation you see all these things
that happen in the past like some of the
things that I tweeted before and so far
so see that's pretty cool alright now
let me show you quickly something about
a stateful stream processing in this
particular case I do have small small
application stream processing
application that includes multiple
things so first thing is this is how I
am creating this Twitter stream from a
raw data because Twitter connector
pushes only JSON to me and this is how
I'm telling this key cycle server that
I'm actually running JSON so to the key
cycle server will be able to parse this
data and work with
natively Kasich oil works natively with
this Jason there are some helper
functions that allow you to extract some
of data from the JSON so in this case it
uses this JSON path to to navigate
through this JSON payload and create
this username using screen name and some
other things so in this particular case
I'm filtering by hashtag so I can use
special functions like that will lower
case all these hash tag entities so in
this particular case it will be using in
this is it name I'll skip that so this
is how I'm defining that how many people
will be tweeting about this presentation
or maybe how many people do tweeting
this so this is why I want to capture
this state that called user a tweet
count that I will be using here so I'm
saying that within one hour window my my
presentation starts almost hour ago
people will be tweeting and I will to
collect account how many people are
tweeted about this this awesome
presentation within this windows period
I want to change the way how I'm
displaying some data so in this
particular case I also can apply the
function that transforms my same thing
that you do with any database related
code and now I'm creating a table from
the table of these tweets where I have
only Twitter account more than if the
people were tweeting more than three
times of me let's see if it actually
works and we'll see if we have any one
who actually tweeted more than three
times maybe my yam I bought it the
tweeted more than four times you can try
to beat this we will say huh
I know this is yep so tweet it and the
count should should also change in the
real time so we will see another event
from this table that will include some
of
data that came from the new tweet come
on come on
they should there should be there should
be something let's try it again
let's do this again just coping again
number one come on dude update update
update update get you a new hashtag too
you see actually this is maybe result
from the up from the previous hour
because they you know we roll over to
two new hours so this why it might be
data from from another from another or
some hour the window already jumped and
let's do number five let's see if it's
actually working
yeah so this was data from previous hour
and this is now fresh data and I have
this you know already deployed you see
this data continuously updating state of
this table alright so if you want to
learn more about I'm sorry too fast if
you want to learn more about stream
processing in general I highly recommend
to go to grab the books that was written
some of the people from from from
confluent specifically I highly
recommend you read the aisle of logs
that will allows you to understand the
this kind of like a mentality behind of
log based data structures and we have a
slack where you can ask all your
questions around if you follow me I will
be tweeting the slides so don't don't
worry about taking picture of this and
one last thing so I was talking about
this demo that runs inside kubernetes if
you available today night and you
interested in kubernetes typo jazz we
will be hosting meetup not far from a
place where we were boring to the boat
yesterday so go register if you want to
learn how this demo works in terms of
some of the kubernetes aspects I really
appreciate that you spend this hour with
me I enjoyed this I hope you enjoyed
this I heard there's some rating system
on this in this conference there's I was
told that the green one
good so probably you also should should
should use green one thank you very much
for your time as always i available for
enhanced interrogation any questions
there's no there's no stupid questions
ask me anything thank you so much
[Applause]